you mentioned uh the the feedback
control the Dynamics sorry for the
Romantic question but is in the early
days and even now is the Dynamics
probably more appropriate for the early
days is it more art or science
there's a lot of science around it
and and trying to develop you know
scientific principles
that let you extrapolate from like
one-legged machine to another
you know develop a core set of
principles like like a spring Mass
bouncing system and then figure out how
to apply that from a one-legged machine
to a two or a four-legged machine those
principles are really important and and
we're definitely a core part of our work
there's also
you know when we started to pursue
humanoid robots
um there was so much complexity in that
machine
that
you know one of the benefits of the
humanoid form is you have some intuition
about how it should look while it's
moving
and that's a little bit of an art I
think and now I'd say or maybe it's just
tapping into a knowledge that you have
deep in your body and then trying to
express that in the machine but that's
an intuition that's a little bit more on
the art side maybe it it predates your
knowledge you know before you have the
knowledge of how to control it you try
to work through the Art Channel and
humanoids sort of make that available to
you if it had been a different shape
maybe we wouldn't have had the same
intuition about it yeah so you're
knowledge about moving through the world
is not made explicit to you
so you just that's why it's art and it
might yeah it might be hard to actually
articulate exactly you know there's
something about
um and being a competitive uh athlete
there's something about
seeing a movement you know a coach one
of their greatest strengths a coach has
is being able to see you know some
little change in what the athlete is
doing and then being able to articulate
that to the athlete you know and then
maybe even trying to say and you should
try to feel this
um so there's something just in scene
and again you know sometimes it's hard
to articulate what it is you're seeing
but there's a
receiving the motion at a rate that is
again sometimes hard to put into words
yeah I
Wonder
how it is possible to achieve sort of
truly elegant movement you have a movie
like ex machina I'm not sure if you've
seen it but the main actress in that who
plays the AI robot I think is a
ballerina I mean just the natural
elegance and the I don't know eloquence
of movement
it's it's it looks efficient and easy
and just it looks right
it looks it looks right is sort of the
key yeah and then you you look at uh
especially early robots I mean they
they're so cautious in in the way they
move that
it's not it's not the caution that looks
wrong it's it's something about the
movement that looks wrong that feels
like it's very inefficient unnecessarily
so and it's hard to put that into words
exactly we think that and part of the
reason why people are attracted to the
machines we build
is because the inherent dynamics of
movement are are closer to right
um because we we try to use you know
walking Gates or we build a machine
around this gate where you're trying to
work with the Dynamics of the machine
instead of
to stop them you know some of the early
walking machines
you know you're essentially you're
really trying hard to not let them fall
over and so you're always stopping the
Tipping motion you know
and sort of the insight
of dynamic stability and a lighted
machine is to go with it you know let
the Tipping happen you know let yourself
fall but then catch her catch yourself
with that next foot and there's
something about getting those physics to
be expressed in the machine
that people interpret as
lifelike or or elegant or just natural
looking and so I think if you get the
physics right
it also ends up being more efficient
likely
there's a benefit that it probably ends
up being
more stable in the long run you know it
could it could walk stably over a wider
uh rain range of conditions
and it's uh and it's more beautiful and
attractive at the same time